[Music]
John I know this was important you
called me you asked you to come out here
and talk about this what is your problem
with the NBA well as a fan of the NBA as
we all were they kind of left us in the
dark for two months they took something
away from us they left us with a certain
emptiness a certain sadness and the NBA
of course has promised to make it up to
us but what I decided to do because I
don't know if I believe that with two
lockouts in the past 14 years so what I
decided to do was to go out and find a
league that cares about its players and
respects its fans like this audience as
well the greatest audience did you find
that you you went and looking for a
league that would respect the fans did
you find such a league
I did find a league here watch this
what's your name mica mica mica and how
do you spell mica Oh with letters yeah
Oh gotcha how much were the tickets to
today's game you don't have to pay a
cent to watch the game nothing that's
great because then you don't have to go
into your piggy bank right so you're
here to watch basketball as well how
much do you get paid to play in the
league zero dollars I don't get paid at
all you'll get paid a cent to playing
why do you do it then for fun yeah are
you a communist
[Music]
do you ever fear that this league will
be locked out much like the NBA was have
you ever been locked out of the house
what's that feel like feels like my
little brother's trying to keep me out
of the house and you would never let the
fans of this league have that feeling
would you nope no because you and I
don't know where my team and 12 exactly
have you guys ever met before this
season the two of you brothers your
voice is different than his we'll say
something yeah that's a little bit
different you're right about that
why do you think the Commissioner of
this league and the players have such a
harmonious relationship because they're
small and they don't know what they're
doing or three is that right I guess so
yeah yeah all right are you guys nervous
that one of the players on the other
team is four foot three terrifying how
great is it that this basketball league
has never locked up its players
I mean they've never in a sense yes they
do never they've always been able to
come to an agreement with their players
so that the game can go on to watch
basketball on me it's almost as vice
playing video games what are you guys
gonna do a play date with Gregory that
sounds like fun
so after a wonderful day of basketball
you're gonna have a play date and maybe
a sleepover right are you guys gonna
call your girlfriends and tell them that
you want you you don't have a girlfriend
do you have a girlfriend
so you
well then you'd probably be pretty open
to a sneaker sponsorship I don't know if
you'd be interested by Conan O'Brien has
put on his own shoe this is the air Coco
it has of course the red hair follicle
sole and the double Windsor tie tone no
Conan O'Brien has come out with a new
basketball sneaker and I'm gonna show it
to you right now
[Applause]
do you like that yeah well you will pay
you to wear it but you got to promise to
wear it everywhere you go no way
everyone and then you're not getting the
sneaker we're done
[Applause]